Now despite all of these benefits, we've yet
to see a significant deployment of IPv6. Here you
can see the number of routing table entries
for IPv6 routes, as well as the growth over
time from 2004. To the end of 2013. What's remarkable
is that we only see 16,000 IPv6 routes in the global routing table. This
is not that many considering that there are about 500,000
IPv4 routes in the global routing table. The problem is that IPv6 is very
hard to deploy incrementally. Remember our discussion
of the narrow waste. Everything runs over
IPv4 and IPv4 was designed to run over a variety of physical layers. This
common protocol has allowed tremendous growth, but
because. Everything depends on the narrow waste
of IPv4 and, because IPv4 is built on top of so many
other types of infrastructure, changing it
becomes extremely tricky incremental deployment where part
of the internet is running IPv4 and other parts have been upgraded to
IPv6. Results in significant incompatiability. There
are various incremental deployment options for IPv6.